المسيره الشاقه مجاعه كوريا الشماليه قد
تتكرر مره اخرى
معاناه كبيره تنتظر سكان هذا البلد الاكثر
عزله في العالم
كارثه مجاعه فتره التسعينيات تلوح في
الافق هذا هو كيم جونغ ال والد الزعيم
الحالي لكوريا الشماليه
بالتزامن مع بدايه حكم الوالد عام 94 حدث
ما لم يكن في الحسبان مجاعه المسيره
الشاقه وهي مصطلح اطلقه الكوريون
الشماليون عندما حاوطتهم الازمات قبل نحو
30 عاما
المجاعه بدات اثارها تتضح عندما انهار
الاتحاد السوفيتي الذي انهى كل الامتيازات
الممنوحه لكوريا الشماليه وقتها عانت جميع
القطاعات وعلى راسها قطع الزراعه هناك ليس
هذا وحسب فبعض الكوارث الطبيعيه التي
اجتاحت البلاد مع قرارات كارثيه من جانب
كيم جونغ ال وحكومته
فقامت الكارثه وادخلت البلاد في نفق مظلم
زعيم بيونغيانج رفض وقتها اتباع سياسات من
شانها السماح باستيراد الاغذيه وتوزيعها
دون تمييز على جميع مناطق البلاد لدرجه
انه كان يتم توزيع الطعام على الناس حسب
وضعهم السياسي ودرجه ولائهم للدوله فبعض
المصادر اكدت ان النظام وقتها كان يغذي
سته في المئه فقط من السكان
والنتيجه كانت الموت بسبب الجوع او
الامراض المرتبطه به الامم المتحده قالت
ان الجوع تسبب بوفاه ما يصل الى ثلاثه
ملايين ونصف المليون شمالي من بين اجمالي
عدد السكان البالغ وقتها حوالي 22 مليون
نسمه والمرعب هنا ان هذا السيناريو ربما
يتكرر مره اخرى في كوريا الشماليه في عهد
الزعيم الابن كيم جونغ اون وهو ما حذرت
منه بعض المنظمات في عام 2018
على الرغم من التحسن في عام 2010 لا تزال
نسبه انعدام الامن الغذائي المزمن وسوء
التغذيه في كوريا الشماليه مرتفعه نحن
نتحدث عن عشره ملايين شخص اي 40 من السكان
يعانون من نقص التغذيه ويحتاجون الى
مساعدات انسانيه نرى طفلا من كل خمسه
اطفال يعاني من سوء التغذيه المزمن
الازمه في كوريا الشماليه مستمره وقد
يزداد الامر تعقيدا فالمخاوف المتزايده من
نقص الغذاء والازمه الانسانيه دفعت الزعيم
الكوري الشماليه للتحرك اجتمع بمسؤولي حزب
العمال الحاكم لمناقشه تحسين اقتصاد
البلاد وانقطاع الزراعي من اجل انقاذ ما
يمكن انقاذه خاصه بعد تاكيد بعض البيانات
الصادره من المختصين بالامن الغذائي ان
الموت بسبب الجوع هناك قادم اللامحاله
صور الاقمار الصناعيه وبيانات الامم
المتحده والسلطات الكوريه اشارت الى
انخفاض الامدادات الغذائيه الحد الادنى لن
يلبي الاحتياجات البشريه وحتى لو تم توزيع
الطعام بالتساوي وهو شيء يكاد يكون
مستحيلا في كوريا الشماليه فستكون هناك
وفيات مرتبطه بالجوع
معاناه صعبه تنتظر اغلب السكان في كوريا
الشماليه فالدوله الاكثر عزله في العالم
باتت تعاني من كل جانب العقوبات المفروضه
بسبب برامج اسلحتها النوويه والتعرض بشده
للكوارث الطبيعيه واغلاق الحدود بسبب
جائحه كورونا بالاضافه الى سوء الاداره
لعقود طويله كل ذلك جعل كوريا الشماليه
تسير في طريق لا ملامح له فصعوبه تامين
الغذاء لشعبه قد تجعل زعيم البلاد يعيد
النظر مره اخرى في جميع سياساته القائمه